字幕: 泰斗 城間
校正: Emi Atarashi
“Hi, everyone.”
“My name is Miho Hashimoto,
and I’m an interpreter.”
“I translate between Japanese
and English.”
皆さん こんにちは
通訳者の橋本美穂と申します
日本語と英語を扱っています
皆さん 通訳って
どんな仕事だと思いますか？
クライアントの言葉を
日本語から英語へ
英語から日本語へと
正確に訳す仕事—
そう思われているかもしれません
ですが 私の通訳は少し違います
例えば 皆さんよくご存じの
ふなっしーさんの通訳です
ふなっしーの通訳は
とても難しいものでした
記者からこんな質問が出ました
「公認キャラクターじゃないのになぜ
こんなビッグ・スターになれたんですか？」
私はこれをふなっしーに伝えました
すると ふなっしーは
次のように答えました
「うーん」
「これは日本人独特の
感覚だと思うけれども
昔っから判官贔屓って言葉が
あるなっしなー」
「判官贔屓って何だ？」
と思いながら聞いていると
どうも ふなっしーには
どこの会社も
エージェンシーも付いていなくて
１個の梨が 一人で活動している
「個梨状態」が
弱い立場の「（源）義経」と重なって
人気が出ているということでした
そこで 私は
“root for”「応援する」という言葉を使って
このように訳しました
［判官贔屓って言葉があるなっしなー］
“We root for the second and under.”
次にご紹介したいのは
ピコ太郎さんです
あの PPAP
「ペンパイナッポーアッポーペン」で
ギネスを取ったときの記者会見でした
世界中の報道機関が集まりました
ピコ太郎さんは
世界に向けてのメッセージを求められて
次のように答えました
「世界中の人に言いたいのは
ありが玉置浩二」
ありが玉置浩二？
このジョークは
どう伝えるべきでしょうか？
私はこれを
“Arigato, or ariga-tamaki-kouji.”
と訳しました
って 訳してないじゃんって
思いますよね
でも これには 実は
ちゃんとしたワケがあります
まず「ありがとう」は
外国人も知っている
日本語ベスト３に入る言葉です
わざわざ訳さなくても通じます
次に 通訳の基本ルールとして
「固有名詞は訳さない」
というのがあります
だから玉置浩二は そのまんま
「玉置浩二」と訳しました
“Arigato, or ariga-tamaki-kouji.”
と言うことで
外国人記者には
「ありがとう」と日本の何かを掛けた
ジョークだということが
瞬時に伝わったはずです
これはなんとか通訳できました
でも 次が問題でした
「驚き、桃の木、20世紀」
これは無理でしょう
“Surprise, Peach tree, 20th century.”
と訳したところで
全然 面白さが伝わりません
私はとっさに
“I’m so surprised, like a peach tree.”
と通訳して
そこで頭が
真っ白になってしまいました
「桃の木のように驚きました」って
全然 意味が分からないですよね
本番中に固まってしまったのは
この時が最初で最後です
本当に辛い時間でした
会見が終わってから
ずーっと 反省し続けました
「何て言えば良かったんだろう？」
そして 考え続けて 36時間後
ようやく お風呂の中で
ひらめきました
それが—
“I’m super duper whopper surprised!”
です
「超マジで めっちゃ驚いた」
っていう感じです
うまいでしょ？
あの記者会見の場で
パッと出てこなかったことが
今でも悔しいです
さて
これまで 私の通訳体験を
ご紹介してきましたが
この時 通訳者は
何をやっているのでしょうか？
実は「正確に」と言っても
一言一句 辞書通りに
直訳しているわけではありません
まず 聞き取った日本語から
情報と感情を受け取り
頭の中でイメージを描きます
次に
このイメージを参考にしながら
英語でこれを再現しようと試みます
ですから
日本語で面白いジョークを受け取ったら
その面白さを
英語でも表現したいんです
私が 言葉を訳すだけでなく
感情とか 面白さも伝えようと
努力するようになったのには
理由があります
私も 最初からこんな通訳を
していたわけではありません
普通に通訳をしていました
でも 通訳をしながら
「これでいいんだろうか？」と
色んな疑問が湧いてきたのです
その気づきを３つに整理しました
１つずつ 見ていきましょう
１つ目は「言葉だけでいいの？」
という気づきでした
言葉を正確に通訳すること
これはとても重要なことですが
「本当にそれだけでいいのか？」
ってことを
深く考えさせられる出来事がありました
改めて 私のことなのですが
私の仕事は別に
コメディアンの通訳を
専門にしているわけではありません
実は「ビジネス通訳」という
仕事をしています
ビジネス通訳とは
担当者のミーティングから
企業の買収など
何千億というお金を動かすための
交渉やプレゼン
セミナー
記者会見など
企業活動に関わる
あらゆるシーンで通訳をする仕事です
私が駆け出しの頃
日本語のテレビコマーシャルを
クライアントに
提案する通訳の仕事がありました
その会議では
テレビ CM が流されます
クライアントは それが
どのように面白いのかを説明します
私も通訳者として
それを英語で説明していきます
しかし—
それを見ている外国人の顔がですね
特に笑うこともなく
真顔のまま見ています
まぁ よくある光景といえば
よくある光景です
「ロスト・イン・トランスレーション」
ってやつですよね
でも 私はここで
「本当にこれでいいんだろうか？」と
悩みました
C Mを作ったディレクターさんは
すごく苦労して制作されたはずです
その苦労が実って
日本人にはウケる内容に仕上がっています
でも 全然
その面白さが伝わらないんです
私はC Mの面白さを伝えたい
そのためには
「ただ言葉を伝えるだけじゃダメなんだ
もっとできることがあるはずだ」
そう思って
言葉だけでなく
感情も伝えられるように
声に抑揚を付けたり
声色を変えたり
するようになりました
すると
真顔で見ていた外国人たちが
吹き出して 大笑いしながら
“This is great!  Let’s do this!” と
即決してくれるようになりました
２つ目は
「文化の通訳」です
日本語と英語では
文法や単語が違うだけでなく
文化が違います
文化の違いを考慮しないで通訳すると
現場がなんだか
ギクシャクしたものになってしまうのです
例えば「検討します」
日本語の「検討します」は
「本当に検討する」
言葉とは裏腹に「検討しない」
「判断を保留する」
などの意味があります
しかし英語の “consider” は
「本当に検討する」という意味です
ですから 外国人に
“consider” っていう言葉を伝えたら
「じゃあ いつまでに結論を出しますか？」
という素朴な質問をぶつけてきます
そこで 私は
日本人の表情や声のトーンなどから
今の「検討します」は
どういうニュアンスなんだろうと探ります
色々ありそうですよね
「考えておきます」
「できるかできないか 判断します」
「しばらく放置します」
「決められないと思います」
「曖昧にしておきたいでーす」
「多分やらないと思います」
これは「意志を読む」という
とても大切な作業です
間違いは許されません
だって もし読み違えて
通訳者がイエスをノーと答えたら
それは誤訳になり
通訳者の責任になります
真剣勝負です
日本語では
意思を明確に示さないことが
良いとされる時もありますよね
一方で 英語は
当然 意思は明確にするものでしょう
という感覚です
この文化ギャップを埋めずに
ただ「検討します」を
“consider” と訳しても 通じません
文化の違いも通訳することで
双方の合意が進みます
最後の３つ目は
「結果にコミット」です
一般的な通訳者は
言葉を正確に訳すことに集中します
でも これだけだと
現場では不十分だと感じました
そこで 私は
感情を伝えたり 文化を通訳したり
色んな工夫をしてきたんです
でも なぜこんな努力を
してきたのかというと
私は
「結果にコミットしたいから」
なんです
「ビジネスを成功させたい」と
強く願うクライアント様がいます
それぞれが共通のゴールに向かって
前に進んでいます
その共通のゴールに
無事に 誤解なく
たどり着けるようにガイドするのが
私の考える通訳の仕事です
そう信じて工夫を重ねてきたら
いつの間にか
今のスタイルが出来上がっていました
しかし 最近になって
通訳・翻訳業界に 激震が走っています
そうです
［強敵現る A I ］
A Iです
A I は果たして 通訳の仕事を
どのように変えるのでしょうか？
私たちの仕事は
無くなってしまうのでしょうか？
最後に このA Iと通訳について
お話しします
まず A Iは 何ができるのでしょうか？
［言葉の通訳、文化の通訳、結果にコミット］
一番左の「言葉の通訳」は
まぁ A Iは今後
どんどんできるようになるでしょう
単純に言葉を訳すだけの通訳の仕事は
A Iに置き換わっていくと思います
次に「文化の通訳」です
果たして 文化の通訳は
A Iにできるようになるのでしょうか？
これは できたり できなかったり
するのではないかと考えます
例えば
先ほどの「検討します」
今の A I には 正しく判断することは
難しいかもしれませんが
次第に 精度は
高くなっていくと思います
「検討します」くらいなら
いずれは いけるでしょう
しかし 例えば 私が
次の言葉を言ったらどうでしょう？
［タコ焼き食べたい］
「タコ焼き食べたい」
A Iなら
“I want to eat Takoyaki.”
とか訳すと思います
しかしそういう意味で
私は話していないんです
私はタコ焼きに
特別な思い入れがあります
私が高校生だった頃です
一人で時間を過ごしたいと思うことが
時々ありました
それは 辛い時だったり
うれしい時だったりして
溢れる感情を噛み締めていたいと
思う時でもあります
そんな時間に 私は
屋台のタコ焼き屋さんに立ち寄って
タコ焼きを買って
一人で食べていました
一人でタコ焼きを食べながら
自分の感情と向き合うんです
そして タコ焼きは
そんな私をホッとする
温かい気持ちにしてくれました
ですから 私が
「タコ焼き食べたい」と言うときは
「一人になりたい」
“I want some me time.”
という意味になります
このような極めて狭い
文化・文脈に依存した言葉は
通訳の現場にも
山のように転がっています
ドラえもんのような
パーソナルA Iが出てくるまでは
「タコ焼き食べたい」のような
個人的な表現を
「一人になりたい」
“I want some me time.” と訳すことは
難しいでしょう
最後の「結果にコミット」です
今のところA Iは
結果にコミットすることは
できないだろうと考えます
ビジネスの成功を考えながら
通訳するA Iは
まだ存在していません
理由はいくつかあると思うのですが
最も大きな理由は
A Iは 明確な「意志」を
まだ持っていないからです
一方で 私たち通訳者は
人間です
人間は意志を持っています
意志を持っているので
クライアントと一緒になって
結果にコミットできます
通訳の現場で強く感じるのは
この意志の力です
意志と意志が共鳴し
ぶつかり合い
コミュニケーションをとりながら
世界をより良いものにしようと
協力しています
通訳は この意志の力を
最大限に高めるために
意志を持って協力する仕事です
A Iがどんどん発達していく現代では
人間の意志こそが
最大の武器になるはずです
それは どんな仕事でも
同じだと思います
自分が何をしたいのか
仕事で何を実現したいのか
社会をどう変えたいのか
意志を持って行動することができるのが
人間の強みです
意志に共感して
意志を通訳し
意志を実現する
それが私の通訳です
ありがとうございました
（拍手）